good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock a storm over social care that
just won't go away for the prime
minister with anger from his own back
benches growing despite the plans
getting backing in a vote late last
night we'll be joined today by the
former health secretary jeremy hunt plus
we'll speak to the labour mp sarah owen
a member of the health select committee
also this morning the first details
emerge of the victims of the christmas
parade tragedy in wisconsin we'll bring
you those from our correspondent at the
scene and
give a dog a phone we'll talk to the
scientist who has invented a device that
means owners and dogs can stay in touch
they literally pick up the phone also
[Music]
who sang that originally you remember
don't you of course you do and taking on
a classic misha paris tells us why she
agreed to a cover version of one of
motown's greatest ever hits it's tuesday
the 23rd of november
devastated to lose three passionate
granny's tributes as the first victims
of the christmas parade tragedy are
named
[Music]
a candlelit vigil for the five people
killed by a speeding suv is held as the
community tries to pick up the pieces
overwhelmed mystified
horrified
and
wondering
how could it happen and now how do we
move forward
bulgaria bust fire at least 46 people
dead including children as tourists
return from a holiday trip
mps back the government's plans for
social care reforms but a bad day for
boris as a lot of his own mps don't like
them
i'm here in the heart of europe austria
enters its second day of lockdown and in
germany there's a stark warning from the
health minister as covert rates rise
across the continent
probably by the end of this winter
pretty much everyone in germany it has
sometimes been said somewhat cynically
will have been vaccinated recovered or
died
but it's true
selling jobs to rich countries sky news
challenges the boss of astrazeneca over
its plan to make profits
we will of course adapt to every
circumstance and countries that have
low purchasing power will will be
supplied at no profit or very low price
and others will pay a bit more
down the street criticized the targeting
of jk rowling by trans activists who
posted her home address on social media
[Music]
good morning everybody the first details
of the people killed during a christmas
parade in wisconsin are emerging as
victims were named the dancing grannies
as they were called performance group
said its members are devastated to have
lost three extremely passionate grannies
last night a candlelit vigil took place
from where joe pike reports
[Music]
24 hours after the city came together to
celebrate they returned to remember
[Music]
now we will read the names of the five
beautiful souls that were lost yesterday
wilhelm
hospital
virginia sorensen
leanna owen
tamara durand
jane coolidge
this time the authorities were taking no
chances using trucks to block the roads
as thousands gathered for a candlelit
vigil
the chief of police among those paying
their respects
how is waukesha feeling tonight
right now our morning
right and we're going to move forward in
the future and heal
this is a very resilient community and
i'm very proud and honored to be
a member and part of this community
overwhelmed
horrified
and
wondering
how could it happen and now how do we
move forward
this event
shows what waukesha really stands for
and and how the how the people care for
each other
on sunday night the first sign of
trouble was the screams
as a large car tore through the crowd of
families hitting adults and children
again
and again
and again
i heard
and saw
the people being hit but what you could
do more than seen is hearing and just
that sound was insane
those injured including toddlers and
three sets of siblings
neil stolzmark has run the karate studio
here for 40 years
everyone was just crying and screaming
and
i ran out to try to help the
victims
one man 39 year old daryl brooks is in
custody his criminal record stretches
back decades
police want to charge him with five
counts of first degree intentional
homicide when he appears in court later
today
there are few signs now of the horror
that happened on this street beyond some
police markings on the ground and yet
the pain
the confusion the shock is everywhere in
this small commuter town everyone in
walk ashore seems to know someone who's
been affected
the theme of this year's parade was
comfort and joy
but in the last 24 hours this town has
witnessed trauma and tragedy but it will
never forget
joe pike's sky news waukesha wisconsin
in other news at least 46 people have
died after a bus caught fire on a
motorway in bulgaria the vehicle was
carrying tourists who were returning
from a weekend holiday in istanbul in
turkey to skopje in north macedonia the
accident happened on this strooma
motorway in bulgaria 45 kilometers west
of sofia not clear yet how the vehicle
caught fire the bulgarian caretaker
prime minister called it a huge tragedy
these are the latest pictures that we
are receiving from the scene as i said
not yet clear exactly what happened but
the accident
and fire did happen at two o'clock in
the morning local time near the village
of bosnick southwest of the capital
sophia
germany's health minister has given the
nation a stark warning regarding the
spread of covid19 he said by the end of
the winter almost everyone will have
been
vaccinated
recovered
or dead
goodness adam parsons is in vienna for
us this morning hello to adam pretty
stark warning there good morning
yeah it is and i think it's a very
interesting intervention from jen spahn
germany of course did very very well in
the first wave of the pandemic and we
see global explorers but this time
around the picture is quite different
infection rates are going up fast uh in
germany
largely this wave of infection is coming
from the east saxony at the moment is
very badly hit and is heading towards
the west and the nervousness of course
is that intensive care units which at
the moment in the west are
in some cases really quite so sparsely
attended will get fuller and fuller and
the knock-on effect will be people
getting infected potentially dying
filling up those intensive care units
and that familiar story of operations
not being done
on other people i remember at the moment
germany is in a political state of flux
angela merkel is still the caretaker
chancellor until coalition government is
put in place and there have been claims
that actually leadership has really
fallen away recently
hence now jens barnes jumping
into that void now this is a man who is
not known i think for jumping out and
making extraordinary sort of
proclamations but here he was reflecting
on the state uh of
the pandemic at the moment and his fears
for the country i think you can hear
what he actually had to say
probably by the end of this winter
pretty much everyone in germany it has
sometimes been said somewhat cynically
will have been vaccinated recovered or
died
but it's true with the highly contagious
delta variant this is very very likely
and that's why we are recommending
vaccinations so urgently even the first
vaccination because whoever is not
vaccinated will get infected with our
protection
pretty stark stuff that from the end now
what i think he wanted people to hear
was that the delta variant is very
infectious i think actually what a lot
of people will hear is that these are
your choices either get vaccinated uh or
you are going to catch it and
potentially you are going to die
and i would say that i think this is a
thing you're saying across europe is
that politicians really trying to hit
people around the head who haven't been
vaccinated and really i think there is a
divide growing between the political
establishment and the large section of
societies often up to a third of people
in the country who haven't been
vaccinated
and that discourse that that lack of
conversation between those two sides i
think is going to have big political and
social impacts in the months of time
okay adam fernando thanks very much
thanks a lot well the boss of the
british pharmaceutical firm which
invented one of the most commonly used
coronavirus vaccines has said the
company will continue providing the job
for free
to poorer nations astrazeneca had been
criticized after it said it would start
to make a profit from the treatment the
chief exec told ian king the firm needed
to recoup some of the vast sums of money
it had spent on developing the vaccine
for a large proportion we spend about
seven billion dollars a year and a quite
a large proportion of our r d investment
goes to the uk
uh close to probably a third but it's a
very substantial investment we make
every year in the uk now obviously
during the last year astrazeneca has
become a household name to people who
would never necessarily have previously
known about you and what you do
how difficult has your job been given
the criticism that you've had from some
politicians
well and you know
our job is in the industry is really to
focus on the science and uh
and and the best science to develop
products and we always focus on this and
we will be criticized because some of
our projects
fail and you know
we have been lucky enough in the last
few years our productivity has been high
and we have had more successes than we
have had failures but failures happen
and we get criticized typically we get
criticized by you know investors or the
media but it's it's part of our life
now until now you've provided the kovit
vaccine at cost you've just said that
you're going to start seeking a modest
profit from it
that's because you want to channel some
of those profits into the antibody
covert treatment yeah i mean we've
always said that we would supply this
vaccine at no profit for a period of
time
and by the end of this year we should be
close to 2.5 billion doses of vaccine at
no profit
and we still have orders to deliver
at no profit next year
and we are transitioning progressively
to a profit position
with new orders and so that will have an
impact next year
what will inform the decision-making as
to which countries which territories you
seek to make a profit from
oh actually what we said is that we will
have a tier the pricing policy and that
will go from no profit pricing all the
way to profit pricing and even the
profit pricing will be uh
generating a modest profit
but for people at uh for country sorry
at the low end of uh
economic
resources we will make no profit and
then we will have a different pricing
policy according to how rich the country
is
well certainly a lot of doses have been
used in the uk let's give you the latest
coveted data should we uh this is what
it's looking like
forty four thousand nine hundred and
seventeen new cases of the virus so
further 45 people have sadly died which
means the total number of people who
have died within 28 days of a positive
test
is 143 972.
sixteen and a half thousand people
received their first dose of a vaccine
in the last day while the number of
people receiving their second dose 13
well nearly 14 000 more than 46 million
people have now had two doses of a
vaccine uh and as far as the boost is
concerned to well almost 238 000 booster
and third jabs taking the total number
of those doses to more than 15 million
government getting on track now with
that
joined now by labour mp sarah owen a
member of the health select committee
hello to you thanks for joining us
should we start with covered while we're
just talking about it there apparently
there's another new variant the
ay.4.2 i'm sure it'll get another cat to
your name but how worried should we be
about it
i think all the while that we do not
take a global response to the pandemic
we are in a global plan to make the
clues in the title and we need an
international response so moves from
astrazeneca that you were talking about
just now are very welcome because we
need to ensure that everyone across the
world has access to a vaccination
and as far as what's happening in
germany and belgium and vienna is
concerned how worried should we be when
we cast our eye across the channel
i think we have always got to be
scanning the horizon for new variants
for changes and possible um solutions
new solutions for dealing with this uh
pandemic and we can't take our eye off
the ball particularly as we're staring
down the barrel of winter again
yeah i do want to go on to ask you about
social care but just a final thought
from the education secretary nadim
zahawi he so far rejected calls for
exclusion zones around schools they were
supposed to be put in place um to
protect the youngsters from anti-vaxxers
who some of them come and cause issues
for the parents and the kids as they're
going to and leaving school um do you
have a view on that should it already be
in place
children should just be able to go to
school i think they've had the horrible
last two years the last thing they
should be doing is being confronted with
people who are being aggressive or who
are looking looking to threaten them or
teaching staff or their parents it's
completely unacceptable children should
just be able to go to school
talk to me about the social care bill um
it passed yesterday you criticized
labour's criticized the bill
what's the alternative
well what we saw last night was
absolutely shocking um and you saw a
number of conservative mps rebel and
completely disgruntled with this as well
because they see the inherent unfairness
we were told that no one would have to
sell their home to pay for social care
and last night the conservatives broke
that promise people with the most modest
incomes with the most modest households
will be losing the most out of this and
that is completely unacceptable and it
doesn't even solve the social care
crisis that we're currently facing it's
completely nonsense
it's a better uh situation than we're in
at the moment though is what the
government would say in response to that
people deserve better they were promised
something and they've got completely the
opposite
and when we're looking at the social
care agenda none of this even solves the
problems that people are facing right
now what we've got 110 120 000 social
care worker vacancies that could
increase as we see workforce burnout
which we discussed on the health select
committee
none of these issues are addressed in
the health and care bill that they're
bringing forward or the vote that they
had last night
talk to me about what labour would do
though um you know it's easy to
criticize the government but what would
labour do in response in your manifesto
back in 2019 you suggested to fund free
personal health care as they do in
scotland and that will cost i think
something like six billion pounds a year
well we wouldn't be um charging and
punishing those with the most modest
incomes and allowing people with
millions of pounds worth of wealth to
not be touching any of this or paying
their fair share i think we have to look
at a long-term funding strategy for
social care and that involves looking at
the wealthiest within our society paying
their fair share how can it be that
somebody with assets of a hundred
thousand pounds only is left with twenty
thousand yet somebody with half a
million pounds would be left with four
hundred and fourteen thousand that is
completely nonsensical and that is the
opposite of what labour would be doing
because they've bought their property
because they've um earned more money
during the course of their lifetime and
they've paid tax on that money and now
they're at the end of their you know
towards the end of their life or the end
of their years and as a result they they
have earned what they've got
i completely don't accept that argument
in terms of somebody working harder
people work hard for whether it is
whether it's i didn't say no no you
mustn't put words in my mouth i didn't
say that at all i didn't suggest for one
second that they were working harder i
was just saying that they had worked
hard all their life and as a result they
had whatever been lucky enough to get a
job that was well paid but as a result
of that they've paid significantly
higher taxes than other people and they
want to live comfortably with the money
that they have paid tax on towards the
end of their lives
and there are a group of people within
society some of the wealthiest who are
making funds not out of an income in
terms of going to work in the same way
that you or i would
but are making money out of wealth out
of shareholding out of pension funds out
of hedge funds and actually we should be
looking to other means and being a bit
more innovative when it comes to how we
fund our social care
and it's not just about the money that's
coming in it's about how the system
works and at the moment we're asking the
poorest and those with the most modest
incomes and middle incomes to pay into a
social care system which is
fundamentally broken and this does not
solve it
so wealth tax
i think when you're looking at the
wealthiest you can call it a wealth tax
but it's ultimately looking at a much
fairer system of taxation than what we
currently see because we are seeing
a double whammy people are being hit and
national insurance people are being hit
with their
potential of having to sell their homes
or the majority of their home and their
wealth and these are ordinary working
people many of them would have been
working in the healthcare sector for
example and we are asking the wrong
people to pay into a system which is
fundamentally broken
am i not writing saying that the top
five percent of earners in the country
pay
90 of the tax or something like that
i think this is again about fairness and
we were promised the conservatives
promised and boris johnson promised the
electorate and people voted on the basis
that they wouldn't have to sell their
homes to pay for social care and last
night that is what they whipped their
mps to do and that is an utter disgrace
but these people who you're talking
about who got their big houses what my
point is that many of them not all of
them i i get your point but many of them
have worked hard all their lives in
those houses and you're saying that they
should have those taken off them
no i think that what we're saying is
that there is a fairer way of doing it
we don't want to see anybody lose their
home because of it but ultimately right
now we're seeing people with millions of
pounds worth of assets um being able to
retain 90 of that and somebody who is in
a two-bedroom or terrace house in the
midlands or in the north of the country
they would have to lose absolutely
everything and that is a very unfair way
of doing things i don't think it's
justifiably fair um i think anybody
looking at it would say that's not
that's not the way to do things we can
do things much better people have worked
incredibly hard or they've saved and yes
everybody would have done that but those
with the broader shoulders should have
to bear the burden
yeah i hear you but my point is that
they've already
had quite a heavy burden of taxation
during the course of their life i'm
asking you because i put that to the
government yesterday of course no one
should lose their homes and that's what
the government one of the planks that
the government won this election on and
you know
economical with the actuality as i put
to the minister yesterday but i'm asking
you given that you're representing
labour this morning
what labour would do
i i've mentioned and i told you already
that i think that people with income
that get it from wealth from
shareholders from pensions give me more
deals
those sorts of things
that would look like people on
model modest incomes and with modest
earnings and with modest households not
having to sell the majority of their
assets but how do you pay for it
i've said that those with the biggest
incomes should have to pay for it and i
think that that is a fundamentally much
fairer way of looking at it and it must
be
what we're seeing right now is knee-jerk
it's not a long time to pay for it
we need to be looking at tax and taxing
those that are the wealthiest in society
because what we see now we've seen now
an increase national insurance we've
seen an increase in national insurance
and now you are asking people with most
modest incomes who are working in low to
middle income um jobs to pay again
tell them how how would you tax richer
people
you can tax rich people there are models
for doing that in other countries and
there are also there are also big
earners throughout this pandemic most
working people have really struggled for
the last two years when you look around
when you look at the likes of amazon
and um some of the big companies that
have made huge profits out of the last
two years we should be looking at taxing
those companies because they are
currently that's not what you were
saying to start with you were talking
about taxing rich people
okay you asked for another way of
possibly raising those funds i've given
you two [ __ ] reasonable explanations
i'm asking you how you do that
i've given you two reasonable
explanations and those are looking at
the world
to you but they're confusing so i'm
asking you to clarify
how it's confusing let me ask you let me
ask you again how do you tax richer
people by buy a penny on income tax buy
a wealth tax how are you suggesting that
you tax people who've got bigger houses
i think i'm masturbating
well the tories have managed to be able
to find a way to tax working people and
tax people on lower incomes yet again
i'm pretty sure that a labour government
would be able to find a way of sharing
that burden much fairer and in a much
fairer way for everybody in the country
which actually solves the social care
crisis not this
in other words you don't know
you know i've just given you two
reasonable explanations looking at those
that have actually made huge profits
over the last two years out of a
pandemic and out of a a health care
crisis fundamentally which they should
be paying their fair share in and not
asking people that have already been
taxed again with the national insurance
increase and people that have saved and
worked really hard throughout their
working life to afford a home that is
more modest than others
okay so people who've got a big house
how are you going to tax them
when we're talking about a wealth tax or
we are talking about taxing the
wealthiest there are many ways of doing
that and i think that ultimately
we should be focused focused on making
this the fairest way possible and this
isn't what we've got we could be doing
lots of different things taxing people
that for example make their wealth out
and their income out of wealth rather
than productivity rather than going to
work in the same way that we all pay tax
and i think that that would be a much
fairer way of looking at it because
it cannot be justifiable
that somebody with a hundred thousand
pounds loses
loses all but twenty thousand pounds of
the of their wealth how can that be
justifiable and last night what we saw
was a number of tourists
not just asking you what do people
just do what you want to happen and you
you're being ideological and you don't
have an answer
i think that isn't completely unfair
i've told you two two ways of doing it
okay whether it is you want to
experience legislation one more time how
do people with big houses pay more so
that people who don't have as much money
don't have to lose their properties just
give me one way that that would happen
are we talking about a mansion tax
so the same way the same way that the
tories are penalizing and taxing the
poorest and the most modest incomes in
our society why is it that you're you're
saying that tories are able to tax those
with modest houses yet they wouldn't be
able to tax those with the biggest
biggest i'm not saying that
so why is it that they would be able to
do it yet label wouldn't be able to do
it for those that are the most wealthy i
think there's always a way around it and
if the conservatives can tax those on
the most modest incomes and working
class people
we would be able to find a way
perhaps people that have got the most
wealth and do that in the fairest
possible way okay um just before i let
you go if you've been to peppa pig world
the prime minister says it's fabulous
um no i have not been to peppa pig world
and i'm not entirely sure the cbi uh
conference was the place to raise uh
what you do on on your break
okay it's good to talk to you thanks
very much indeed for joining us on the
program come down and see us we'd love
to have you in the studio it's great to
talk to you thank you
thank you jay
thanks a lot from pages this is how they
are treating the social care story this
morning the guardian says mr johnson
delivered a rambling speech to business
leaders it quotes several conservative
mps as casting doubt on mr johnson's
ability to lead the party after what one
former cabinet minister describes as a
pretty bad fortnight the metro says the
prime minister made a peppa pig's ear of
the speech it compares his address to
theresa may's an infamous 2017
conference speech in which she developed
a bad cough and when her party logo fell
off the wall do you remember that
and the daily star asked could someone
at number 10 please check on bozo
johnson its headline verdict on the
speech a pork pie short of a picnic
that's quite funny actually
uh still to come on the program for you
could germany use mandatory vaccinations
to stop the new wave of covered
infections we'll talk to a leading
german scientist shortly
joined by campaigner
after she won one of the most
prestigious environmental awards for her
work in madagascar the latest on that
and animal rights campaigners tell us
why there are that why they are
protesting against the queen's guard's
best in caps worn by british soldiers
[Music]
also this morning for you the funeral of
the murdered mp sir david amis will take
place this morning thousands of people
including politicians from all parties
are expected to join his family for the
service at westminster cathedral
the actor kevin spacey and his
production company have been ordered to
pay more than 30 million dollars to the
studio that made the hit netflix
show forgive me house of cards after he
was fired following sexual harassment
allegations he's denied all the
accusations against him made over the
last few years
jk rowling has revealed that her address
was made public by a group of activists
who took photographs of her home and
posted them on twitter
ashna is in the newsroom for us ashna
tell us more about what happened good
morning
good morning the author has repeatedly
been making headlines for her views on
transgender rights if you remember last
year she wrote a particularly polarizing
article where she took issue with the
phrase people that menstruate when
referring to people instead of talking
about women but this revolves around a
photo that three activists took outside
the author's home but that she says
clearly depicts her address and in it
she says uh that tweets responding to it
she said over the last years i have
watched appalled as many women and she
goes on to name a number being subject
to campaigns of intimidation which range
from being hounded on social media the
targeting of their employers all the way
up to doxing and direct threats of
violence including rape i have now
received so many death threats she said
she said i could paper the house with
them and haven't stopped speaking out
doxing it's worth mentioning as a form
of trolling it's essentially putting out
someone's private information with
malicious intent downing street has also
condemned this photograph and says that
nobody should be targeted in that way
and the twitter accounts of all three of
those individuals have temporarily been
suspended
okay lovely thank you ashley thank you
if you're a nervous flyer
then look away now as one airline not
looking took on one of the last great
challenges in aviation you'll have to
let me know what it looks like because
i'm not looking natasha my director i'm
not looking the charter airline high fly
has landed one of the biggest aircraft
ever to touch down in antarctica the
airbus a340 flew from south africa to
the south pole on the first regular
supply flight of this year's summer
season it landed on the wolf fang runway
which is made up entirely of glacial ice
the remote location meant the plane also
has to carry enough fuel for its return
flight to africa still not looking quick
look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
cold and fairly calm for the next day or
so with the risk of overnight frost but
it'll turn very unsettled to end the
week central and southern parts are
mostly clear dry and frosty now while
the cloudier north is mainly frost free
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now a labour mp has this morning
suggested on the program that a wealth
tax could be used to fund social care in
england 19 conservative mps last night
rebelled against the government over its
proposals for funding adult care short
time ago labour mp sarah owen who sits
on the health select committee told me
it might be necessary to raise taxes for
the better off
at the moment we're asking the poorest
and those with the most modest incomes
and middle incomes to pay into a social
care system which is fundamentally
broken and this does not solve it
so wealth tax
i think when you're looking at the
wealthiest you can call it a wealth tax
but it's ultimately looking at a much
fairer system of taxation than what we
currently see because we are seeing um a
double whammy people are being hit and
national insurance people are being hit
with their
potential of having to sell their homes
or the majority of their home and their
wealth and these are ordinary working
people many of them would have been
working in the healthcare sector for
example and we are asking the wrong
people to pay into a system which is
fundamentally broken
tamara's here she wouldn't double down
on what the manifesto had said as far as
labor was concerned on how to pay for um
social care that's right i think okay
the prime minister's clearly had a bad
time yesterday there was a big rebellion
in the social care vote 19 toys voted
against it dozens more clearly weren't
convinced and didn't vote at all
including some big hitters like theresa
may and other former cabinet ministers
but given that this social care stuff is
hard the prime minister has said look
the system we've got at the moment is
not fit for purpose the system that he's
proposing is not is not perfect clearly
there's a question about inequality but
it's more generous than what we've got
now what would labour do about it well
when the prime minister first announced
all of this some months ago and said
we're going to have to raise everyone's
national insurance in april next year to
pay for it kierstama's response was that
labour would have a wealth tax what does
that mean well clearly his mps don't
really know because we don't know
whether it's going to he's talked
vaguely about properties and about
shareholdings but exactly how it work is
not clear and what is that going to fund
labor say we don't like this cap the cap
is not fair so what's the alternative
she she when asked whether they would do
what jeremy corbyn as leader promised in
2019 which is free personal care in
england that's what they've got in
scotland so some of your care costs
covered by the government that's
expensive cost six billion a year she
wouldn't commit to it clearly all these
questions will need to wait for the next
election but kierstama is going to keep
getting those questions because this is
a difficult issue and the government
made that tough decision to raise
national insurance it's not going to be
popular people aren't going to like it
it raises 36 billion pounds raising
finding a wealth tax that raises that
amount of money that people will accept
might be a more difficult job than
labour expect tomorrow's take we've got
tomorrow's take today hopefully at nine
nine o'clock look forward to it thank
you
now the german health minister has
warned people they should expect to have
been vaccinated
recovered or died by the end of the
winter much of western europe is in what
the german chancellor angela merkel has
described as a dramatic fourth wave of
covid infections
dr uh joining us now is dr uh hey joseph
from the leibniz institute for
prevention research and epidemiology
hello thank you very much indeed for
joining us do you agree with the
sentiment from the minister
well it's a very tough stance i guess
but in principle this is what we're
heading for it's uh we have high numbers
of infections now and uh i mean this is
clearly meant as a as a stark warning i
would say and uh yeah i think we need
this at this point
um how concerned are you about the
situation in germany at the moment in
the rising numbers
yeah we really have uh strong surge in
numbers and in many places in germany
the the numbers are excessively high we
haven't seen this uh
through all uh the pandemics
so yeah it's it's very concerning and i
mean it's basically the hospitals again
that are the bottleneck and we will be
really in we are in trouble in some
places and we'll be in trouble in more
places over the next
months
yeah
when you say in trouble in trouble in
what way that the health
service that you have in germany is is
in danger of being overwhelmed um that
um
the business can't cope because not
enough people are at work in what way
oh it's mainly the the health system
that's the consideration right now
because the intensive care units are
really flooded uh already in in some
places and they they are
clearly warning that this will get worse
and that they will face you know triage
but they have to select who can be
treated and cannot be treated which is
really something that they don't want to
do at all business-wise it's not such a
such an issue at present because most
people um this is organized and there is
the refunds for those people who cannot
go to work so this is not really so much
of an issue but it's also coming up
obviously
um the outgoing chancellor angela merkel
has said that the present curbs though
are just not enough what do you think
yeah it's it's it's true we are we are
having a slightly different situation
than in the uk where you have been
having these high numbers for quite some
time now and also took a different
stance here it's uh it's probably
politically not not acceptable really
that's why people are really getting
worried now and are thinking about you
know
reducing the contacts mainly again
closing down uh venues and stuff like
this which hasn't been there for a while
but it's coming up now clearly and also
the question of this vaccination
mandatory vaccination yeah i wanted to
ask you about that what's your view on
mandatory vaccination i was speaking to
a doctor about it actually from the
world health organization just yesterday
it's clear so if we got along without it
it was better but it's getting tough and
uh it seems like we we will have to uh
go that past this the the discussion is
out there really you know which is the
climate has really changed the general
opinion is
uh tilting towards you know going for
mandatory vaccination it has its
problems it's clear but
we need you know 10 or 15 more
vaccinated adults and that's that's
perhaps not something that we can reach
otherwise
where are you with boosters are boosters
as important to other people of germany
or the everyday life of keeping the
country running in germany as they
appear to be here in the united kingdom
15 million thereabouts have had their
vaccination out of i'm trying to
remember a population of well over 65
million
uh we're not that far we started uh
later with a boosters but it's now
there's a big big surge now the idea is
to have
more than 20 20 million people
vaccinated after christmas which is a
a high number i'm not sure that the
system can manage because we actually
close down the vaccination centers now
they have to be reopened so these are
things that need to be or are being you
know changed
as we talk basically but it's going to
be a tough uh
activity to get all this done in the
next uh in the next few weeks really but
it is the main issue also now boosting
the you already vaccinated yes
and what are we thinking about um any
future lockdowns or
at least closing the borders of germany
we've seen what's happening in austria
of course
interestingly the the border issue is
not such a big discussion as we had
last last year really it's really the
the lockdown the
the the change in in public life such
that only recovered and vaccinated
people can take part in anything
basically this what we call 2g rule is
is now you know becoming widespread and
that's that's something but we have in
bavaria already you know these contact
restrictions people you know and some
places cannot leave their home if they
are uh if they're not vaccinated in fact
so we have restrictions we have partial
uh uh you can call it lockdowns in many
places and we'll probably have more of
this coming up but what about as far as
the borders are concerned i mean are you
looking across the channel to the united
kingdom and thinking they've got another
variant in the uk we don't want that
pesky variant over here
yeah even if we were looking i mean the
variance they are faster than what we
can do anyways so i think this this
discussion is not not really at the
at the top of the list and presently we
are all in it uh jointly and i mean the
vaccine
uh will stop quite a lot of the
the infections but
um closing borders and we've seen it it
really doesn't doesn't do a lot
especially not between the uk and
germany i mean this
i don't think is on the agenda now
and as far as um
getting rid of covert um finally uh
getting rid of covid altogether we heard
from our former vaccines minister who
was speaking just yesterday and he said
the uk will be the first country to see
the back of kovitz 19. do you have a
view on that
well uk is certainly uh you know ahead
of some other countries because of the
the spread that
the infection has had in the country and
the good vaccination numbers now both
together will put you into an endemic
state and not now but maybe after the
winter but many countries actually are
looking into this just right about india
that they are there as well even south
african countries where no vaccinations
but actually the
surge of inspections has gone through
the population so um yeah
england and the uk are there and will be
there in some months but this will be
tough month ahead of us in the winter it
won't be easy even for the uk and the
nhs in particular
and do you think boosters sorry i've got
another question i've thought of a
follow-up uh boosters do you think we
might have to have them every year like
the flu vaccine
it's not yet not yet clear but it's it's
possible really i mean we are going to
have a base a basic level of immunity
coming up more and more with these
boosters and and
maybe the
the actual uh variant will not be as
severe anymore in the near future so
this is hard to say but it's quite
possible that we will need to get
vaccinated but we'll be in an endemic
state and maybe there will be sort of
smaller outbreaks we hope that this is
all losing its threat basically over the
next years
fascinating to talk to you doctor thank
you so much for taking the time much
appreciated
cheers thanks thank you
uh one of the countries uk's biggest
refuse firm says it's seen a huge rise
in the number of attacks on bin men
during the pandemic it says in some of
the worst incidents workers have been
attacked with acid and baseball bats
what's that about shiny marariki reports
laszlo's work as a refuse collector is
grueling
there are early starts long hours and of
course dealing with hundreds of
households waste every day
one thing he does not expect to face on
this daily drive through north london
though a difference he said to me if i'm
not going to delete that recording he's
going to kill me
last month following company policy and
not collecting rubbish placed in the
wrong bin saw him and his colleagues
chase down the street
during this period the residences
arrived with the bike started to break
in and tried to break into the lorry
bang on the door on the window he's
yelled on us he's gonna beat you he's
gonna be kill us and if he's get in he's
gonna be slightly throat off so it's
like that so we driven off
we was very frightened at that point
when you actually wake up every morning
and you think oh shall i go home in one
piece today or not
or how it is
that trauma is now becoming far too
normal from verbal assaults to acid
attacks and even having shots fired
refuse collectors and staff working for
the waste management company violia have
reported 118
increase in incidents like this in the
last year
that is why the company are now taking
action
we're taking a proactive approach to
working with police forces and local
authorities so that our teams know how
to engage with the police how to support
the police to lead to a successful
prosecution and it's part of a bigger
trend after a year of key workers being
celebrated for their work at the height
of the pandemic adulation has turned to
abuse
88 of shop workers have been verbally
abused in the past year while 58 of
transport workers have been threatened
assaulted or spat at since the pandemic
began
there's hope the law could be used as a
deterrent
it is a real shame that you know after
all of the heroic work by frontline
workers
across public services
throughout the
pandemic i think councils are saying
with one voice that they will look to
prosecute those who abuse their staff
for people on the front line like laszlo
promises of protection and more
prosecutions are a vital step in making
sure abuse is not part of the job
shingi maraike sky news
a campaigner trying to protect rare
species in madagascar from extinction
has been awarded one of the most
prestigious international environmental
prizes
julie razafmanak took the tusk award for
conservation for her work to preserve
some of the most endangered creatures on
earth and i'm pleased to say that she is
with us now hello to you julie
hi
hi did you meet prince william
oh yes
very exciting
i'm sure how was he what did he say
well he was encouraging us um to
continue working on conservation in
madagascar it just not only me it's the
five uh universe and finalists of the
task award
a huge privilege to meet him directly
yeah i'm sure i'm sure it must have been
absolutely amazing we know it's a
subject that's very close to his heart
uh you're being honoured as we know with
the award what aspect do you think of
your work are you most proud of or is
that just too difficult to say
um
well there are many aspects of the
work we are doing creating protected
areas in madagascar which has been
difficult but then we go through all the
process
um
saving the
endangered species for example the
golden mantela fork
which has been listed as critically
endangered and now being done listed to
end endangered uh but i think another
really important uh aspect of it is a
growing capacity of
young conservationists in madagascar and
also the communities um which are close
living very close to these uh forests
and the areas where the
where the endemic species are found
yeah and we um we were covering actually
madagascar on our program a couple of
weeks ago for cop26 our alex crawford
one of our reporters our specialist
reporters was there talking about
climate change and the impact that it's
having um on madagascar i'm guessing you
would agree with that yes definitely
there at the moment you can see like
rivers uh trail up in madagascar which
uh some of them have never seen that
before
um
and also in the south with the tropes
and famine
it's it's really
a big challenge for us in madagascar to
adapt to it and to find the strategy to
survive
[Music]
despite the changes
yeah um just a quick thought before i
let you go julie what's next you've won
this amazing award you've met uh prince
william what are you going to do next
um going back home
i have to go back and take these
a word um to the communities we have
been working with to get it
uh and then um
we'll have to continue uh
pushing on youths and um and other
communities to do more work in
conservation and of course um
raising the capacity of my team so that
we can do better
and really in all aspects
and to make it
i'm so sorry but it's absolutely lovely
to talk to you congratulations on your
award and safe journey back home thank
you for joining us
thank you very much
what a wonderful girl uh coming up all
today's top stories here on the
breakfast show on sky stay tuned
[Music]